The Dimple code to draw the bar chart is only actually five lines of code.
In D3 this would take around 30 lines, and introduces many
more sources of error if we have to code 30 lines of code, rather than five.
This really goes a long way to show how proper abstractions can go
a long way towards developer productivity.
The first line here simply creates a new
chart object in the specified element with the specified data.
The first argument is a D3 selection that represents the SVG element.
Which we would like to append our Dimple chart to.
And the second argument is a JavaScript object representing the data which we
would like to display.
In this case, the SVG is, was returned from the d3.select call.
Or what is rather returned from the D3 code
that initially appends the SVG object.
And the data object passed to dimple.chart is simply the same JavaScript object,
in this case, an array of JavaScript object literals,
that gets passed to the draw function callback.
>From our data loading function.
The data loading function is below our window here but its simply D3's.TSV
function which loads a tab separate value file in this case world cup.tsv.
And once it gets loaded via AJAX, passes that data content,
to the draw callback, which we see here.
So the flow, which sometimes takes some getting used to,
is a call to d3.tsv pass in a data file.
Once loaded, the data file gets passed to draw.
Which we can see here in our callback function.
And this data object is the same as the contents of our
World Cup file which then gets passed in to the dimple chart constructor.
There are a few other ways to manipulate the chart object itself if you
are interested.
And I definitely recommend always reading the documentation of any
function you use.